now the u.s election
the presidential debate earlier this
week was a disgrace viewers will have
seen the low lights
if not you can catch up on them with the
spectator tv us election special from
wednesday night it's up on youtube
we'll have a montage there and analysis
but is it a taste of things to come
the outcome of this november's election
is likely to be more fraught than bush v
gore in 2000 our cover piece this week
explains exactly why and i'm joined now
by matt purple
senior editor of the american
conservative and he penned that cup of
peace
matt welcome i want to come on to uh
some of the things that might happen on
on election day and in the immediate
aftermath you were writing about them
but i want to put something more broadly
to you for your reaction
i get the sense of the trump campaign's
in real trouble now
he was in trouble before went into the
debate uh and it's in trouble
more trouble coming out of that debate
and
a lot of them are not sure how they're
going to get this show back on the road
and that he's probably going to lose
yeah i mean it really was the chernobyl
of debates it was absolutely a disgrace
like you were saying before
it you know we have never seen anything
even remotely close to that in american
history and i think
that the crazy thing about it is that
the president reportedly walked off the
stage thinking he had done a good job
you know patting himself on the back and
he really stuck it to joe biden
and they took his advisors going to him
and telling him no you really
you went on too hot like you came on too
strong uh you got to dial it back last
time and
so i i think that draws in a problem
here which is that trump is so willful
and he's so determined to be donald
trump he can't really be anything else
he can't change his stripes
that you know if you have to alter your
course if you have to come off as a
little bit more civil in the next debate
or try to correct your errors
trump is not somebody who corrects his
errors he is somebody who declares
victory even when he's in defeat
uh he's somebody who rarely ever
apologizes for anything so
his handlers are going to be struggling
with that and i think
you know biden has been ahead
consistently in the polls
the one thin read of hope that trump
voters or trump's people have hung on to
is that 2016 situation where an awful
lot of people
didn't tell pollsters they were voting
for donald trump because they were
embarrassed they were a bit sheepish
about it
there was kind of this invisible man
factor that came back and propelled him
over the edge just at the end or over
the top just at the end
and everyone is on the right is crossing
their fingers and hoping that's going to
happen again this time
the problem is you know you still need
to win over independent voters you still
need to bring back some of those
uh catholics and the de-industrialized
rust belt states that you won last time
around you need to
to reel in some political independence
uh
how many undecided voters watched that
nuclear storm and
thought oh yeah i really got a good show
with the candidates there i mean i was
really able to
discern who i'm going to vote for i
really learned something
uh nobody at all if anything they're
just going to be repelled by donald
trump
if you stand back a bit and think all
right what's mr trump got going for him
he's probably got the economy going for
him he pulls better than mr biden
on that he's actually had too many
people surprising some reasonable
foreign policy
policy successes his hard line with
china is
the new normal in in washington now even
mr biden
who used to cozy up to the chinese was
attacking the china
in in the debate um he's brought offers
a remarkable feat of the uae
and uh bahrain opening diplomatic
relations with israel
uh and a lot more of these gulf states
are going to follow
but i would suggest his problem is that
rather than talking about these things
or bringing these sort of things to the
poor
which would make him seem a bit more
presidential if that's possible
this bluster this heckling this
hectoring
is all people see and the noise obscures
any of the substance he made his own
temperament the issue
which i think was the problem he made
his disposition the issue
and uh the public liked that to an
extent in 2016 they were in a very
rebellious mood
but he was also running against a very a
wildly unpopular
democratic candidate a candidate who
from the beginning like from the time
she entered the democratic primary all
the way back in 2015
had a massive trust deficit in the polls
people did not like her
he's running against somebody this time
around who's genuinely more likeable you
know i think you can present a better
contrast who comes off that way
i think the answers that joe biden gives
at the debates are going to be weaker
than hillary clinton's but i think
overall he's a better package for
independent voters and
the problem is if trump comes off in
that boorish manner if he draws all that
attention to
you know onto himself well first of all
you're on the risk that the public is
not in quite as rebellious a mood this
time around
second of all you run the risk of you're
the incumbent you know you don't just
get to
to you know punch people around you
don't just get to
pump your fists in the air you have a
record to defend
you're supposed to be containing some of
these problems you're supposed to be
pointing to things that you were able to
accomplish
not just absolutely flamethrowing your
opponent which is what he came off into
and also behaving with some kind of
presidential decorum i
remember this isn't he's no longer just
the host of the apprentice he is now the
president of the united states
and inevitably is going to get judged
with a different prism or through a
different prism i think because of that
and yeah it you know it i think it
called attention to the worst of donald
trump i don't think that biden
necessarily rose above it
i don't think that you can call that a
decisive win for joe biden per se
uh i i think it was just you know
negative hellfire all around and trump
ended up getting burned the most
i wonder if the the republicans are
right to
put so much faith in the polls being
wrong i mean the polls will always be
wrong
to some extent but this time around they
they've made a number of changes they're
correcting for education
which they didn't do before they uh
because education had never been a huge
factor in how
people voted in 2016 it was a huge
factor
in how people voted and they're
correcting for that they've brought in
they're more uncollege educated those
who have
left high school or even didn't leave
high school
with a diploma there are fewer
undecideds now many fewer
than there were the last time mr biden
has twice the lead among women than
hillary clinton had
in pennsylvania which mr trump has to
win
mr biden's rocking it in philadelphia
he's sweeping the cybers as well
particularly with the soccer moms and so
on but he's holding up in the western
counties as well
which is what got mr trump
the victory last time around and when
you look at
all that justin pennsylvania and the
plenty of other governors i would
suggest matt
i think donald trump realizes he's going
to lose
he's certainly going to lose the popular
vote and he will probably man lose the
electoral college vote
so he's already planning the ground for
that he's going to say
that i won on the day i won by the
people who turned up to vote the honest
way the old american way
all these votes that have since come in
in the following week
are fraudulent they're fixed you can't
count on them
i still won that will be a
constitutional crisis will it not
it could be yeah if biden doesn't win in
an absolute crushing landslide or
you should say trump doesn't win an
absolute crushing landslide it could be
and you know this gets back to what i
said in my piece which is that
uh you know we we americans like to
follow to file lawsuits well we've been
filing them over this election already
there are more than 300 lawsuits that
have already been filed even before
voting starts
most of them by republicans most of them
worried about the mail in balloting they
do have some reason to be concerned
uh during new york's primary elections
for example back in june
uh there's a lot of mail-in balance we
have more mail-in ballots than usual
right now because of the coronavirus so
they're encouraging people to mail their
ballots in rather than going to polling
places
and in new york's primary there ended up
being real chaos afterwards it took them
weeks to determine the winner
uh they ended up accidentally throwing
out a bunch of ballots
a number of ballots that they shouldn't
have that they then had to reel back in
it is not it did not give confidence in
our electoral system and
there are partisans on both sides who
are lawyering up
uh who are extremely polarized to an
almost existential degree you know who
think that if the republicans or
democrats get elected this time around
it's not just going to be bad it's going
to mean the end of that that really is
that the peated political climate in the
united states we're dealing with
and who think okay we're going to fight
this as far as we possibly can we're
going to take it as far as we can
and then into all of this comes the
death of a supreme court justice ruth
bader ginsburg
taking the supreme court down to an uh
and even
eight justices so it could the high
court could split evenly if it comes all
the way up to that
uh in that case it wouldn't be like in
the year 2000 when
the supreme court determined by a 5-4
vote the winner of that election
you know gave it to george w bush and
you could end up with a situation where
you have to go back to the lower courts
but there's multiple lawsuits multiple
lower courts
different standards are applied in
different states that creates confusion
it allows both sides to declare victory
and suddenly
we are in the likes of a constitutional
crisis that we have never seen before
well in the year 2000 there was only
florida really in contention
in 1876 there were four states in
contention
naturally including florida it almost
seems to be there
and uh it took them four or three months
to resolve these four states sent
different delegates
of electors one for tilden the democrat
one for rutherford hayes the republican
and they sent teams of both to support
them and it was only resolved with
56 hours to go and in these days
the inauguration was until march it's
now in the constitution
that it's on january the 20th it could
be a very
given mad final question to you on this
given
the febrile mood in so many american
cities at the moment all these
people walking around with automatic
rifles and so i mean only in america
could you see that um it
it it seems to me it's a dangerous time
for the united states
and uh what happens if in that 11 week
period president z
decides it's time to make a move in
taiwan or president putin decides
let's put the screws on latvia
who's going to be running the country
yeah well semi-automatic rifles andrew
let's not go too crazy here but it's
anything about guns they're walking
around with really big guns
yeah it says
right it's it's a very fraught
potentially violent situation
and uh i actually said 1888 election on
the podcast this morning
so you're right it was 1876.
the subtext of that is that samuel
tilden the candidate who ultimately lost
rutherford b
hayes was in the white house his
supporters never let them forget it they
they always claimed that he was robbed
they never let go of it and so you had
this situation over the next four years
where there was
legitimate tension you know where there
is an illegitimate president in the
minds of a lot of people
and trump is already illegitimate in the
minds of a lot of people on the left
they don't think that he won fair and
square he snuck in with the minority of
the popular vote
uh you know stuck by in the electoral
college and
so you're dealing suddenly with this
question of presidential legitimacy
of what happens if even if you do manage
to get a winner in there even if you do
manage to have somebody declared
what if half the country doesn't accept
it what if they do turn
to violence in the streets what if you
know that is the
the match that lights up the powder keg
and i i really don't know
i i grew up in a time in america the
1990s when we seemed to be totally
stable you know the soviet union had
fallen
uh we were king of the ho the hill
people were talking about a unipolar
world and the united states could do
whatever
we wanted and everybody was looking up
to us and now suddenly
uh we're that problem nation you know
we're that nation over a barrel
and uh i think we can get out of it
there's no reason to think that we can't
our our history has been much more fraud
and violent than a lot of people
sometimes think you know we've
we've kind of been here before uh but
but certainly enormous challenges and
and dark times in america potentially
going forward
that election of 1876 resulted in the
compromise of 1877
which gave rutherford hayes the white
house but it gave to the racists and the
segregationists the south
and after that compromise of 1877 there
was not a fair election
for blacks in the south until 1968.
there was a big price to pay i just
wonder what it will be this time
you